[Music]
hi I'm Mike Seymour of ethics guide comm
reporting for Wired on the tech behind
the visual effects of World War Z I
could get into Russia for what I started
Russia's a black hole I need answers
some amazing action sequences but to
pull them off one of London's top visual
effects companies the Moving Picture
Company or MPC had to effectively work
out a formula for swarming zombies how
did the filmmakers pull it off so well
well the zombies are not animated by
hand they're intelligent agents that are
programmed with a form of AI that allows
them to interact MPC used their in-house
program Alice which normally allows
these agents to avoid bumping into each
other
of course here they needed to climb all
over each other as senior CG supervisor
max wood from MPC explains NPC was many
sequences in World War Z the largest of
which was Saint Jerusalem Israel the
Israel sequence which was Malta the
biggest challenge they're seeing was
Elijah Samba Crouch ops
our environment team built a large wall
around Jerusalem we see our zombies come
over we also got a large CG environment
outside the wall with wastelands at our
backdrop showing Jerusalem all this was
built from photo reference early on we
receive concept work showing the
different shapes the crowd could take
somewhat pyramid like a similar like
freestanding tentacles made of zombie
crowd for the pyramid shots we start off
to find the shape and the layout the
crowd could take will then start
populating the layout with motion
capture clips including performers
climbing up nets falling down ramps and
falling off objects the largest pyramid
shots made up from around 5,000 zombies
[Music]
the digital zombies come from a database
built of motion capture performances
which are then randomized with a core
set of attributes which have variants
applied to bring out what seems like
thousands of different zombies unlike
perhaps the zombies in the film each of
the intelligent agents in MPC's alice
program effectively have a mind of their
own they act by being given an objective
a set of rules to achieve it and then a
simulation is run even the NPC artists
have no idea exactly whether or not
they'll succeed when they started for
the best shot we use various different
motion capture clips including
performers running up a ramp jumping up
from the height of the bus all complex
crowd shots have got layers of
hand-animated zombies which start off
setting the shots of malice our in-house
crowd tool then would work out where we
wanted to add the additional animation
detail one of the branches of Alice's
they makes it really easy to work to him
in different departments
[Music]
in the street scene we start off working
out and speeding the layouts got it to
be very dense without to have a flowing
form and friends the crowd we had a fast
running zombies there was some hose fall
over and end up being eaten up by the
zombies behind them
[Music]
towards the end of the Israel sequence
we see the zombies attack a helicopter
in some shots the helicopter was
live-action but in others where they
actually need to be more extreme we have
the CG helicopter our zombies can
interact with what's amazing is not only
did they simulate all these agents but
they also simulated their wave-like
movement and then they added cloth
simulations camera simulations and of
course photorealistic lighting on every
single shot that's a lot of simulations
well if you want to learn more about the
world behind the visual effects of some
of the biggest blockbuster films be sure
to subscribe I'm like say more for wide
[Music]